vous êtes la crème de l'
aristocratie française et l'envie de toutes les cours
d'Europe mais quand je vous regarde, je vois
la corruption, les ténèbres, la tentation, le meurtre du
mari, ils doivent toujours m'accompagner
immédiatement, vos relations continues avec
l'Amérique encourent une dette et le
règlement des comptes  n'est pas encore payé je construis ces
murs pour me protéger contre les menaces
de l'extérieur une
grande attention est avec ça le poison
les ombres appartiennent le silence à part le changement
crois-moi j'y ai participé
[Musique] tu me
manques je
vois
donc tu dois mettre fin à cet Iturbe  avec sa
majesté,
Rome doit être informée qu'elle doit garder
son nez romain hors de nos affaires.
Je dis que vous êtes allé à Waddle pour me combattre, mais
pour échapper à l'enfer que deviennent les Visayas
et la contagion se propage toujours, c'est dans
mes murs, c'est dans mon sang.
est-il étonnant que je n'aie pas dormi
cache chenil original preuves d'exorcisme
bleu bleu total s11 plus plante même set
souris